hey guys what's up I'm Alana and welcome
to my channel when I was in Paris games
week a couple of weeks ago now I got
some behind closed doors time with meaty
molecules dreams and while it's so fresh
in my mind I just wanted to talk about
what dreams actually is and I think this
is one of the first times ever that I've
encountered a game that I don't know how
to explain and I love that about it
instead of calling it a game I would
actually describe dreams as hmm a social
media for people to share things that
they have created using the same
software while you can play games within
dreams and you can make games within
dreams it's totally not limited to a
game formula think of it as like being a
face book but on LSD or if DeeDee and I
had like Photoshop built into the
website so you could follow your
favorite artist and check out the stuff
that they're making within dreams you
can make statues which can be perfectly
3d printed you can make short films you
can make other video games you can make
anything that has any kind of animation
but at the same time doesn't need to be
animated because it could just be a
statue or a painting an example of
something that I saw behind closed doors
session was one of the devs was making a
character that would presumably live in
a video game world and it just really
evolved beyond that when he was playing
he made a head made some eyes and then
made a hat and then somehow the Hat got
its own statue and tree and birds which
he then animated to fly around some of
that stuff was made using a premade
library of things like the tree was
pre-made and presumably as content
creators upload stuff there will be like
enormous libraries of things for you to
choose from but some of that stuff he
crafted in the game itself similar to
photoshop using different paintbrushes
different colors different textures to
sort of just warp a thing
it was meant to start out as a character
that you were using something else and
it turned into its own
world just by him zooming in and adding
things and changing the scales the face
of this character he made was really
insignificant in comparison to its
animated hat it's basically just that
you can link together different worlds
and make whatever you want to do
whatever you want and take people on
these weird journeys which I guess is
why they have to call it dreams because
I think a lot of it is going to be
totally nonsensical so as for me
personally I think that I would use it
more as an observation thing where I
would follow one guy because he makes
cool short films and then another girl
because she makes really weird statues
inspired by video games I like and then
another person because they make high
action first-person shooters or maybe
another person because I want to make a
creepy game likes Linda in a forest and
they make a lot of different kinds of
trees so it's a social network sharing
platform for creatives yeah yeah I'm
happy with that I want to thank you guys
for watching I will see you all next
time bye